welcome to the last lecture it's a
smaller group of people today so yeah so
just a quick announcement the project
reports are due next Friday so just make
sure that you return those and yeah
poster session was awesome so I showed
up for a little bit of it but the the
posters that I saw was really amazing
and I really enjoyed like talking to the
groups I talked to and good job on all
the projects it was great we were going
to have best poster or word thing - and
you're going to announce that on Piazza
later so just an announcement on that
okay all right cool so let's must
conclude the lecture so CS 221 so the
plan for today is we're going to do a
quick summary of what we have talked
about so general summary of the class
like all the things that we have learned
and then I want to talk a little bit
about some of the next courses that you
might want to take after taking 221 if
you were in 229 I know in the morning
they they went over a bunch of next
courses from the perspective of 229 all
the AI courses one would want to take
we're kind of doing a similar thing here
but from the view of 221 what would be
some of the next courses that would be
good to take and then after that I want
to talk a little bit about the history
of AI we did this in the first lecture
so it would be a little bit of a review
of that but then I want to talk a little
bit also about some of the next
directions that might be interesting to
think about and some of the research
that is done currently in various topics
of subtopics of AI and what are some of
the problem is that people are
struggling with so it would be fun to
think about that and if you're
interested in any of that you can go do
research in that area or take classes in
those particular areas so that's kind of
the plan for for today's lecture it's
gonna be shorter than usual so I think
it's gonna be probably an hourish okay
all right so so let's talk about the
summary of the class so we started the
class talking about this paradigm of
modeling inference and learning right so
we started thinking about how there
exists a real-world problem you're going
to pick up a real-world problem and
we're going to do modeling so modeling
would be an abstraction of that
real-world problem and in general we are
in
and reasoning about that real-world
problem like finding the shortest path
or solving some sort of optimization
about that problem and we call that in
France right so we had a model of the
world and then you would do inference
reasoning on that model and the idea of
the learning the learning part of the
lectures was that well our models are
not going to be perfect right you're not
going to be perfectly model everything
in the world instead we might have a
partial model and in addition to that
you might have some data around the
world and around the things that are
happening in the world so you would like
to use that data to to learn about the
model and kind of complete our model so
so this was kind of the common paradigm
through the class and and this was the
topics that we covered we started with
machine learning and retreated machine
learning as a tool that allows us to
better learn these models parameters of
these models and then we talked about
various levels of intelligence in the
course right so so we started with
reflex based models then we increase the
level of intelligence a little bit
talked about state based models variable
based models and and finally logic so
let me briefly just remind you of some
of these some of these topics so in
machine learning kind of the common
thing that you started looking at was
this idea of loss minimization so we
have some data we have some training
data inputs and outputs X and Y's and
then we define some sort of loss we
looked at different types of loss
functions and properties of these loss
functions and then the idea was we would
want to minimize this training loss for
the hope of generalizing to a new
scenario right for the hope of if I get
some sort of new input I would be able
to give the best output possible with
respect to that so so I would in general
I would like to minimize my test tester
but one way to go about that is to
minimize this training loss based on
some set of variables that we have in
our model and the approach that we
followed for that was using techniques
like a stochastic gradient descent so
this would be the most common thing one
would want to do so we have this loss
function how do I go about optimizing it
I take the gradient and move in the
negative direction of the gradient so so
stochastic gradient descent was commonly
used when we were doing a lhasa
minimization so so these two things like
like writing out the loss minimizing
and doing something similar to
stochastic gradient descent this was
kind of common across a lot of different
machine learning algorithms that we use
throughout the course and we applied
that to a wide range of models so we
would like apply this to all sorts of
models that we had and reflex based
models or state based models it was kind
of the same framework throughout so and
in the first set of lectures that we had
we started talking about reflex based
models the simplest form of which was
these linear models if you remember
regression like we would have this
linear class regression classification
we had these linear models linear
classifiers and we just wanted to learn
the parameters of that and a more
complex version of that or things like
neural networks or deep neural networks
or even like nearest neighbors would be
an example of these reflex based models
and what was in France well inference
was pretty easy when it came to these
things right inference was just a
feed-forward run of your model and that
would give you the output so we weren't
doing that much hard work ready when it
would come to inference and in terms of
learning well we looked at stochastic
gradient descent we looked at other
things like alternating minimization as
a way of learning these models okay so
that was reflex based models then
increasing the level of complexity they
started talking about state based models
and and the key idea that I want you
guys to remember from from the state
based models is it's the idea of like
what is a state a state is a summary of
all past actions that is sufficient to
choose the future actions optimally and
then we spent a good amount of time
thinking about how to define a state
like how to pick a good state and how to
how to do this this modeling when it
comes to state based models and and we
looked at things like search problems or
we have deterministic systems we looked
at things like MVPs when when we are
playing against nature we have a little
bit of a stochastic city and then we
looked at things like games where you're
playing against some other intelligent
agents there's some other intelligent
agent that's coming in and playing
against us and in terms of inference we
looked at a couple of really cool
algorithms we talked about uniform cost
search and a-star
we talked about dynamic programming
value iteration and minimax that we
covered a set of number of different
different ways of intelligently looking
these models and doing inference and
when it came to learning he looked at
structured perceptron Q learning TD
learning reinforcement learning in
general but those were some of the
learning algorithms that we applied when
it came to state based models so so that
was state based models then then we
moved the level of complexity and
intelligence a little bit higher and we
looked at things like variable based
models and the idea of variable based
models was that the ordering of these
states doesn't really matter it's just
the relationship between them that
matters and may find things like factor
graph so if you remember the map
coloring example we defined a factor
graph around it and and the idea was
there's a scrap that graph structure
Adhir captures the conditional
independence between different variables
that we have so the different variables
in this case was these different
provinces and then you would want to
color them differently and the
relationship between them is going to be
represented by a factor the two types of
models we discussed in this setting were
constraint satisfaction problems and
Bayesian networks Bayesian networks but
in the case where we have probabilistic
relationships and and we talked about
inference and specifically backtracking
forward backward beam search Gibbs
sampling as various ways of doing
inference on these algorithms and I came
to learning we looked at things like
maximum likelihood and em2 try to do
learning on these done these types of
systems and then finally the last few
lectures we've been talking about logic
so pushing the level of complexity just
a little bit higher and thinking about
formulas like actual like logical
formulas that represent intelligent
things about your system so so the key
idea of logic is we're gonna have these
powerful formulas that are going to
represent powerful like meaningful
things about your system and we talked
about things like propositional logic or
first and first order logic and we
talked about model checking which is
commonly used in satisfiability we
talked about modus ponens resolution as
various types of inference algorithms
that could be used when you have logic
and we didn't really talk about learning
when it comes to logic and I would say
this is kind of like an open question
still like how do you combine ideas from
learning and ideas from logic and get
the best of the both worlds like there
are ways of combining
them but how do you ensure that they're
getting best of both worlds like from
data-driven ways of looking at things
and model-based looking at way of
looking at things so so what did CS 221
gave us really the CS to Tony one is
this is this class where it gives us a
set of tools to look at the world and
and and think about difficult problems
in the world and pick the right models P
computer right like way of formulating
that problem and the right inference
algorithm to go about solving them so I
would say it's pretty much like we've
covered a lot of material so so we
covered breadth like pretty broad set a
set of topics and the idea of it is to
know that you have all these tools and
you can pull out these tools and you can
go deep in any of them but but but the
goal of CS 221 was to just give a broad
view of what is artificial intelligence
and what are some of these tools that
that we would have so but if you're
interested in going a little bit deeper
in any of these topics that we've
discussed in the class are a good number
of classes that that you can take any
one just briefly mention some of them an
overview of some of these courses so I
would categorize the classes the next
classes that you can take into into two
main categories you can take
foundational classes that you go deeper
in some of the foundational things you
are talking about or you can take
application classes where you go deeper
in like the specific applications like
natural language processing vision
robotics the specific applications that
we kind of briefly covered in this class
but we didn't go that deep in so so if
you're interested in foundational
classes some of these other AI base
classes are things like probabilistic
graphical models so 228 if you're
interested machine learning there's 229
and 220 90 and there is the deep
learning class if you're more interested
in optimization side of things there is
convex optimization decision-making
under uncertainty and also if you're
interested in logic side of things then
there's this logic and AI course and
also there's a there's a big data class
to that if you're interested in that so
I'm going to go a little bit deeper in
some of these courses but this is just
more of an overview of some of the
foundations and if you're an X courses
that you might be interested in taking
and all of these are also posted on the
AI website so I thought Stanford that
they do you slash courses so so that's
foundations but if you're interested
more on the applications
of things there's a good number of
courses around natural language
processing I'm gonna go again a little
bit deeper in some of these courses and
then there's a good number of courses
around vision good number of courses
around robotics there's also this other
course around
general game playing which would be fun
to take if you're interested in that
side of Thanks all right so so let me
just briefly mention like one slide on
some of these courses that I think would
be good courses to take after this class
so so one of these is CS 228 so CS 228
is a probabilistic graphical models
course if you remember the variable
variable based models part of part of
the lecture this would be kind of the
next course that goes deeper in that so
so we talked about algorithms like
forward backward variable elimination
but if you take 228 you'll be talking
about more general type algorithms like
belief propagation variational inference
Markov chain Monte Carlo and so on and
another thing that 228 is going to cover
is in variable based models like the way
we treated things was the model was
given the structure was given to us
right you would say well this is an hmm
and given that it's an hmm I'm gonna do
these extra things on it but in 228
you'd actually be thinking about
learning the structure learning the
right structure to put in and and how to
think about these different variables
and the relationships between them so if
you want to go deeper in that that would
be the corseting another interesting
course to take and some of you might
have already taken it is the machine
learning course so in this class the way
we treated machine learning was just as
a tool right like we we had a few
lectures on it and we just learned about
machine learning just enough for us to
do some of the things we want to do in
this AI course but but it's definitely
broader than what we have discussed in
the class and some of the ways that it
is it is broader and more general than
what we have discussed in the class is
first off in this class we talked about
discrete actions and and discrete and
discrete time discrete action and state
type systems 229 is going to cover a
more broader set of set a set of models
were you actually thinking about
continuty a little bit we talked about
linear models 221 we'll talk about
kernel methods decision trees
boosting bagging feature selection like
all these sorts of different types of
algorithms and models that are go that
are gonna go beyond
we have discussed in this class we
talked about k-means they were going to
talk about more broader set of
clustering algorithms like mixture of
gaussians pca ica
all these sorts of things so a really
useful a good class to take if you if
you want to just learn more on the
machine learning side of things more
from a practical perspective if you're
more interested in a theoretical
approach a theoretical side of machine
learning there is this other course
called 229 T so this is statistical
learning theory and this is going to
actually think about the mathematical
principles behind learning so so it
doesn't necessarily cover the particular
algorithm but it's going to cover like
properties mathematical properties
around that algorithm saying things like
uniform convergence let's say you have a
predictor and you want to make sure that
that predictor with high probability is
going to have some bounded error how are
you gonna bound the error of that how
are you going to bound the tester with
respect to the training error and some
properties of of your predictor or how
would you formalize things like regret
of your learning algorithm so so
thinking about complexity thinking about
putting bounds convergence regret these
are going to be the topics that will be
discussed in the statistical learning
theories yes to 2019 so if you are more
theoretically minded I think this would
be a good course to take so now thinking
more on the application side of things
so a couple of good applications of AI
after this course are things around
vision NLP and robotics I would say
those would be kind of a three main
applications that you might want to
consider going deeper and if you're
interested in any of these areas if
you're interested in visioned or a good
number of classes around vision there
are a lot of interesting tasks around
vision some of them are more solved and
some of them are more researching things
around like object recognition detection
segmentation but also things like
activity recognition right like if I if
you have frames of different frames of a
video of say a soccer game how would you
predict where the ball goes or how would
you predict where the person goes in the
next few frames like that's actually a
pretty difficult problem like doing
activity recognition from just frames of
images so if you're interested in some
of these problems from the vision
perspective
I would recommend taking 231 type
classes so robotics would be another
interesting application to look at so in
robotics in general we are interested in
problems around manipulation and
navigation and grasping so the main
applications that you might think about
are things around self-driving cars
medical robotics assistive robotics and
the interesting thing that robotic
Springs is that there's a physical
system sitting there so you're putting
your AI algorithm the things you have
developed in this class and some stuff
beyond it on this physical system
physical robot and you need to deal with
things like continuity you need to deal
with things like uncertainty and you
need to deal with physical models that
could come from kinematics and control
so there are a lot of interesting
robotics classes if you're so so I think
intro to robotics is offered next
corridor sama kitv's teaching it but
there is also a new robotics series
course that just came out so this is the
robot autonomy 1 & 2 so advertisement
for myself I'm teaching this next
quarter at markup Ivana and Jeanette
spoke so this is a robot autonomy -
robot autonomy one was already offered
in the fall and and the idea of robot
autonomy one is to just cover the
different layers of the robotics stack
and at the end of the day they actually
have this project it's really cool
project where you have you have a robot
platform and you have a lighter on top
of it and you want this robot to just
move around in a fake city so if you're
interested in I think the project the
project presentations is not already
done so so if you're interested it can
show up to do and and see how how these
robots are moving around but they
basically have this fake city where this
robot just navigates around in this fake
city and does autonomous driving so you
can see a picture of a bicycle in the
back for the robot it's detected and the
bicycle is actually like moving so
detective and do obstacle avoidance the
coordination and with other agents
around it in this particular environment
so that next robot autonomy one in robot
autonomy - which is which is offered in
winter what we want to do is you want to
put a manipulator on top of the robot so
we're looking at mobile manipulation
where we actually have an arm and we
have this arm pick up objects and blocks
and put them on top of each other and do
interaction so the class is - - big
chunks of the class
four is focused on interaction with the
world with the physical world and
interaction with other agents so there
are interesting multi agent like game
theoretic questions that could come up
and you have multiple robots trying to
interact with each other so ideas from
games could come up there like naturally
all right so so that was robotics and
then another of interesting application
is natural language processing and
natural language processing games
particularly very interesting because if
you think about it the role this
continuous but the words that we are
using are discrete and these discrete
words have continuous meanings so
there's a lot of mismatch between the
fact that we have discrete words and
continuous world and and and we need to
use these words to describe the
discontinuous world and there are very
interesting questions and challenges
that arise in NLP around like
compositionality and and grounding and
if you're interested in these types of
tasks I think there are a lot of again
interesting tasks that are more soft
versus less solved and more research II
around NLP so if you're interested in
any of them I would recommend taking
classes like 224 so some of these tasks
are around like machine translation
let's say text summarization dialogue
some of them are much harder like text
summarization dialogue those sort of
things so and we had a couple of
homeworks around this so if you're
interested in going deeper in that I do
recommend taking an LP classes so those
are some of the foundation and more
application II courses that I would
recommend taking I want to briefly
mention two other courses - that are
that are not necessarily directly in AI
but during a neighboring field that that
would be still interesting to look at
one is looking at cognitive science so
so cognitive science in general looks at
how human mind works and it's one of
those fields that that kind of grew
together with AI right like the
cognitive science and AI they kind of
started together and they went their
ways but they still tend to inform each
other and there's a group of cognitive
scientists who are looking at
computational cognitive science and they
use ideas like Bayesian modeling and
probabilistic programs when they look at
cognitive science so there's this course
psych 204 which is cross-listed ICS 428
I think Noah Goodman teaches this usual
and and I think this would be a great
course to take if you're interested in
the cognitive science side of things and
you would have ideas and topics from
other other cognitive scientists like
Josh Tenenbaum and Tom Griffith and Noah
we're working in this particular area of
computational cognitive science so
that's one but if you think about
cognitive science as kind of the
software here and neuroscience on the
other hand is the hardware of the
problem so so another neighboring field
that you might be interested in looking
in a little bit deeper is neuroscience
and if you think about neural networks
like back in the day when they first
start like when people first started
looking at neural networks they were
kind of thinking of them as
computational models of brain but
today's neural networks modern neural
networks aren't really like biologically
plausible in any ways right so they're
not really models of of the brain but
still they're they're interesting
they're interesting connections and
insights that could be used in
neuroscience from the perspective of AI
or from AI to neuroscience so I do
recommend taking kind of cross section
neuroscience courses with AI think Danny
means would be someone who works in this
area if you're interested in looking
deeper in courses around neuroscience
all right so that was kind of a quick
summary of what we have discussed so far
in the class what are some next courses
you are interested in taking sink deeper
around them if you're interested in
learning more around and just come come
chat with me I'm around like if you want
to talk about them but for the rest of
the class what I want to do is I want to
just do it quick like history of AI
again and then after that let's just
talk about what are some of the problems
like what is left like we've talked
about all these cool algorithms tool
sets but what is difficult what is not
solved so so I want to spend a little
bit of time on that so let's talk about
history of AI all right so birth of AI
so we talked about the searing the
overview lecture this was the first
lecture we couldn't came in and were
like okay how did I happen so the press
of AI really like people refer refer to
it as this workshop that happened in
1956 this was a summer school in
Dartmouth and basically everyone famous
in the field showed up to this workshop
including people like John McCarthy
Minsky Chanin all of these people showed
up to this to the summer school and the
reason for the summer school was to kind
of understand the general principles of
intelligence so what they really wanted
to do was they wanted to figure out all
the features of intelligence and if they
could formalize that they could go ahead
and like simulate that and have
similarly intelligence that is what they
really wanted to do and the workshop was
really useful because after that these
people went back their ways and then
started doing really cool stuff and this
was the first rise of AI and we started
seeing things like problem-solving type
type type systems things like Samuels
checkers program which was able to kind
of beat a strong amateur level player we
started seeing other types of
problem-solving programs like theorem
provers and then people like started
really using logic as a way of thinking
about AI and thinking about
problem-solving so that was really
exciting because people like at a time
were thinking they have just solved
everything like it was exciting logic
was there like people had all these cool
programs they were super excited about
the the potential that that these
systems can bring here are some of the
quotes from people are on bad time
things like machines will be capable
within 20 years of doing any work a man
can do so this is what Herbert Simon
said Marvin Minsky said within 10 years
the problems of artificial intelligence
will be substantially solved cloud
Shannon said I visualized a time when we
will be two robots what dogs are to
humans and I'm rooting for the machines
so none of these really happened but one
thing to notice is these are not random
people on the street like these are like
fathers of the fields like these are
people who were like in in it's like
they were like looking yet there they
had a lot of insights like in terms of
what is chaotic what we can do and what
we can't do and it's kind of interesting
that even like them like they had all
this like overwhelming optimism and this
did not pan out right so so there was a
lot of optimism here and and we started
saying really underwhelming results so
lots of optimism government came in
government was like here's my money take
my money go do stuff and basically the
problem that government was
excited about was machine translation
right so they wanted to a crushing takes
and translate that and and the outcome
of that was something like this so the
translation is the vodka is good but the
meat is rather so that's not really like
a good translation of that text and
people started feeling like these types
of problem solving algorithms are not
gonna do it so so and at that point then
the government cut funding and this was
the first winter of AI so we had the
rise of AI with problem solving with
that summer school lots of excitement
and then it didn't really work when it
came to machine translation and then we
had like the first winter of AI one
thing that I want to kind of like point
out is is you're at a good place for AI
right now right like I would say like AI
right now it's also pretty overhyped
right and then I wanted to put this code
here so this is from Roya Mara who says
we tend to overestimate the effect of a
technology in the short run but actually
underestimate the effects of it in a
long run like if you don't think about
any system any technology that we have
developed it's always like oh within two
years it's gonna solve everything and
it's not gonna solve everything within
two years but if you look and what it
has achieved in twenty years it's
actually achieved a lot of things and we
usually underestimate that and I think
it's the same thing with AI like we are
going to think oh we're gonna have a ton
of ass cars tomorrow or by 2020 actually
Thomas car companies were saying you're
gonna have autonomous cars by 2020 when
I first started working on that that's
next month I don't think you're gonna
have autonomous cars Oh a 2020 but
you're going to see a lot of advances
like we are seeing a lot of improvements
in terms of the algorithms in the
systems that we are developing so so I
think in general we should be aware of
that and we should be we should be smart
about it it's like like sure AI is
overhyped but what can we do to actually
address some of these problems and I'm
going back to this first era of AI just
problem solving era but why didn't it
work well the reason it didn't work was
we had limited computation we had
limited information this is the thing
that we actually like started this class
off we said well a lot of AI algorithms
they haven't changed that much right but
but the thing that has changed over the
years is we have lots and lots of
computation we have lots of lots of data
and that's the thing that has really
made the bigger difference here and
that's kind of like one of the
that it didn't work but even though like
we had these problems and we had this
first winter of AI there were lots of
interesting contributions from that era
the Lisp programming language came out
around that time garbage collection came
out that time time sharing like really
interesting foundational ideas of
computer science emerged during this
period and also this key paradigm that
we are using in this class thinking
about separating modeling and inference
that actually came out around the same
era to like the fact that we should have
this declarative model thing and at the
same time this procedural inference
algorithm kind of separated out from
each other and think of them as separate
things like is a huge contribution that
came out around that time alright so
that was kind of rice up and down of
first up and down away the second rice
of a I was around 70s and 80s this is
when the knowledge based systems came
out the expert systems and I would argue
that the reason that we had the second
rice was people people started thinking
about AI differently like originally
people wanted to build artificial
intelligence because they were
interested in intelligence they were
interested in understanding intelligence
that that's kind of what the summer
school was about but at this point
people were not interested in in
intelligence what they were interested
in was just building really useful
systems that can do things like they
didn't care about intelligence at this
point and and that's why we had this
rise of expert systems or we think about
logic and we think about using domain
knowledge to have things like
if-then-else type statements like if we
have a premise then we have some sort of
conclusion and and building these
experts expert systems allows us to do a
lot of cool tasks in in the real raw so
like we had we had actual impact around
this time on things like inferring
molecular structures like diagnosis
diagnosis of blood infections things
like converting customer orders in two
parts and specifications so actual
applications in the world people started
taking each of them and thinking about
the expert knowledge that you have in
that particular application and
formulating that in these expert based
systems and I'm putting an AI on top of
it that does
actual work so that was really cool so
the contributions of this era is that
first off we had real applications that
actually impacted industry and and this
domain knowledge the idea of I'm gonna
pick the domain knowledge and this
knowledge is actually going to help me
make exponential growth was the thing
that that was really powerful at this
time but well why did it work it didn't
work right this was the second rise and
we had another winter the second winter
of AI so the second winter of AI came
because there was a bunch of problems
one of the problems was knowledge in
general it's not deterministic right
like we have a lot of uncertainty when
we think about knowledge and and these
systems were not able to like encode
uncertainty the way we want it to be and
in addition to that there was a lot of
information right like if you think
about any of these expert based systems
that requires a lot of many manual
efforts to write down these rules and
all these relationships between all
these different sub parts of the system
so an example of that is shred loose so
shred Lu is one of the first natural
language understanding programs computer
programs this was written by Terry
Winograd was at Stanford now I think
this was when he was at MIT and and he
created this system this computer
program where you have this block world
environment in it and you can actually
have a person that interacts with this
computer program and maybe the person
says pick up a big red block and the
computer says okay because the computer
understands what like the relationships
between big and small and red and
different colors and where the blocks
are placed and what can be picked and
what cannot be picked right so so this
had a whole bunch of relationships and
and rules around around it and you could
actually converse something with this
computer program and that was really
powerful but even even Terry himself
like a couple years after had the
statement talking about his worries
about how how Shred li-like programs
extra blue are not going to solve the
problem they're not gonna go all the way
like he was saying this is kind of a
dead end in AI and and thinking about
these complex interactions there's just
a lot of them and it just doesn't seem
feasible to write down all these rules
that you would have between each one of
your sub parts with with other parts are
parts and there is no easy footholds so
so at this point people were thinking
this complexity barrier is not gonna
really allow these AI systems to do cool
big things so then we had the second
winter of AI and then finally this is
third rise of AI that you're so on and
god knows where it's gonna come pound
again is this modern modern view of AI
that started around 1990s and then I I
would argue that this this morning I the
reason that we had this this new rice is
due to two main things one is the idea
of using probability in AI this was not
a thing that existed from early on this
is actually due to efforts of Jude a
pearl who was very adamant about using
Bayesian networks in AI to model
uncertainty so so finally people were
able to to use probability to bring
ideas from probability to model
uncertainty because if you remember like
expert based systems they were super
deterministic like we didn't really have
a way of talking about uncertainty but
dude a pearl pearls idea was let's bring
probability in this let's actually talk
about uncertainty and let's have our
models and make predictions and then the
second reason is machine learning right
so so people start inventing support
vector machines to tune parameters and
then from that point on we started
seeing the rise of neural networks and
the fact that we have lots of lots of
data now and that can actually help us
build better models so so given that we
have these two two big new viewpoints
and in AI
we have started seeing all these new
advances and at one point that I just
want to make at the end of this is is
that AI is really a melting pot of a
bunch of ideas from different fields
right like not all of these are from
pure AI right like if you think about
Bayes rules it comes from probabilities
these squares come from an astronomy
first-order logic well from logic
maximum likelihood from statistics we
have ideas from neuroscience econ
optimization and algorithmic algorithms
theory control theory like we can see my
value iteration that came from Bowman
from the field of control theory so it's
really like if you think about
artificial intelligence it just brings
all these different ideas from these
different fields together to solve this
AI problem and in general I think it's a
good idea to be mindful of that and to
be open to that because the new insights
ideas really come from like having this
broader view of things and kind of the
boundaries you put between different
fields are really superficial and don't
really need to be there alright so so
that was a history of AI right like rise
of AI downfall arise downfall and then
we're on this this last rise now so so
let's just think a little bit about what
have you chief what are the cool things
you've had in the past couple of years
and then what can go wrong and what
should be what should we worry about
okay alright so so I think I've argued
enough that AI is everywhere right like
AI is being used in consumer service and
advertising in healthcare transportation
manufacturing and and AI is going to
make decisions now right because like it
has shown all these advances and because
of that like we're using AI DS days to
make decisions for us to make decisions
for our education to make decisions for
credit employment advertising health
care all of these different applications
so so if a is making decisions then we
should actually be really careful about
how I is making decisions and the fact
that we should we should think about
like all the possible things that could
go wrong or could not go wrong and
understand the system fully before
making it make decisions for us so so
what are some of the advances so what a
huge advance that we have seen in recent
years is this Google neural machine
translation so the idea is this was kind
of a huge advance when it comes to
machine translation
the idea is you could have a bunch of
different languages and you can have a
way of translating let's say from Korean
to English and English to Korean you can
have a lot of data on that and that
would be great
and then maybe you can have Japanese to
English and English to Japanese and
trained on that and that's a lot of data
and that's all great
but then even but if you put all of that
data in the same like a melting pot then
whether you can do is you can actually
go from Korean to to Japanese without
having any data that just goes directly
from Korean to Japanese and that's kind
of exciting right like because you have
you had like new data for that and if
you're putting all of these together
then you can actually make a lot of
advances in terms of language
translation so this came out around 2016
lots of excitement language translation
just became so much better after that
there
still problems here is one of them so
here is the problem of bias okay so
let's say you're starting from language
like Hungarian that doesn't have gender
and then you start from this language
and then you go to English language that
has gender and this is a translation
that you're gonna get you're gonna get
she's a nurse and he's a scientist and
and and she's a baker and of course he's
a CEO alright so so you're gonna get
like all these like gendered furnace
here that there's no reason for well
just just by looking at it and assuming
that the algorithm is neutral there is
no reason for it to pick up like these
particular genders but the reason that
it's picking up these genders is this
algorithm is trained on data our data is
biased if our data is biased the
algorithm has learned to pick up pick up
patterns so it's gonna pick up this bias
and sometimes even reinforce it so so
we're gonna see all sorts of these weird
behaviors I'm gonna say it's weird it's
biased behavior but we should actually
be aware of this if you're building
these types of systems and even in
addition to bias bias I can explain it
you might get weird behaviors that are
even harder to explain so you might have
a text that looks like this like dog dog
dog dog dog and then that could be just
just translated to like something else
that is kind of crazy so so like under
like understanding what goes on and a
lot of times with these kind of closed
form black box systems are a little
challenging and I think there's a lot of
research around trying to better
understand and give transparency to some
of these systems and understand what
goes on so that was that was language
right that was translation another
example is image classification so image
classification has just become so much
better over the years around 2015 it
just hit human performance so we have
image classifiers there's just much
better than humans and and that is
amazing right like that is really
exciting because perception is a
difficult problem if I can do image
classification then I can use these
systems of real real worlds like systems
like my phone or my autonomous car and
that's really exciting right right but
there are again a lot of issues around
this one of the issues we actually
discuss this in the
lecture is the idea of having
adversarial examples right so I can have
accent a system that does image
classification and an alux net is going
to classify these images on the left
perfectly fine that's a school bus
that's a temple like it's going to
classify them correctly but then what I
can do is I can add some sort of noise
to them and when you add this noise to
this picture you're gonna get a third
picture and that kind of looks like a
school bus to me like I don't know I
can't tell the difference between the
first and third picture but what's gonna
happen is that Alex that is going to
predict ostrich for all of the pictures
on the on that side on the right so so
that's not great right that having these
adversarial examples it's not that great
because the system is not really robust
right you're you're AI based image
classifier is not very robust when it
comes to just adding these sort of
adversaries another and then after this
work came out basically people started
writing all sorts of papers about how to
create adversarial examples and how to
be robust towards that particular
adversarial example and in breaking that
again and creating more robustness and a
lot of back-and-forth one of my favorite
papers actually around this area came
out this year so this is from Samir and
others and what they have shown is for a
specific type of a neural network when
you have Ray loose what they have shown
is what you can do is you can always
make the system classify the classify
the numbers in this case as something
else so so let me give a concrete
example so this is an amnesty data set I
have numbers in it from 0 1 2 3 4 I have
10 numbers here right and and what
Shamir and others have shown is you can
pick this 7 and you have 10 classes so
you need at most 11 pixels so pick 11
pixels that they pick the 11 pixels
carefully so it's not any 11 pixels but
peeking 11 pixels and change it as much
as their algorithm totally tells you and
then the 7 is going to be classified as
0 so you can make this 7 be classified
as any of these numbers 0 1 2 3 4 or 5 &
6 & 7 & 8 & 9 by just picking the right
11 pixels to modify and they tell you
like how much you modified it's just
like crazy because like
give me anything I'll create this
adversarial example for you two to just
misclassify that's something else and
you only meet eleven pixels because
there are ten classes here so there are
a bunch of assumptions that I haven't
really discussed here like one of the
assumptions is the way you're modifying
these pixels is unbounded in this
picture so the the greens and reds are
just very high and very low so it is not
actually between 0 to 255 it's it's
numbers greater than 255 and less than 0
but they've actually shown that if
you're allowed to have more than 11
pixels let's say you have 20 pixels you
could actually fit it between 0 to 255
to make it like a realistic realistic
figure
anyway so lots of work around this lots
of exciting theory work and practical
work thinking about adversarial examples
when it comes to images but yet what are
the implications of this why are we so
scared of this because well these
systems are going to run on our phones
doing image recognition in our cars
doing recognition of other vehicles and
they can easily be like they can easily
be attacked a group at Berkeley
dongsaeng's group what they did was they
had these stop signs and they put
stickers and stop signs again the
stickers are at the right place like the
place they wanted it to be but then the
stop signs are are now classified as
like a speed limit sign which is not
what you want your autonomous car to
detect or here's another example in
other work where you have these pictures
and you put these funny glasses on them
and when you put the glasses on the
pictures and they are classified as the
celebrities pictures so you can easily
attack these systems not easily but you
can attack to systematically attack
these systems and that can actually
affect the security of your your vehicle
or your image recognition system all
right another example that's pretty
challenging is around reading
comprehension so so what is reading
comprehension so if you remember your
SAT or GRE liked I type type exams you
have a text you have a lot of text and
you have to read that text and you have
to answer questions so you'd have a
question like this so the number of new
Huguenard colonists declined after one
year so this is the thing you got to
answer so so Google put out the system
burped which
actually really amazingly you can can do
this this reading comprehension and
birds can answer this question perfectly
it's gonna say 1700 and that's great but
but what people have shown is you could
actually just add an extra sentence at
the end of this text that has nothing to
do with the rest of the text like that's
something to do it has a word year in it
but but it doesn't have to do anything
with this particular question that's
asked and now Bert is going to respond
1675 so you can again easily trick the
systems and the way they're tricked is
just not the same way that humans are
tricked and and that is I guess weird to
people and that's kind of expected but
but that is something that we are
dealing with these days all right so
another example so I'm basically going
to talk about a bunch of examples
throughout the lecture the rest of the
lecture so another example I wanted to
briefly talk about is this idea of
optimizing for clicks so so is that a
good thing is that the thing we should
be doing right so sometimes the
objectives that we have the rewards
function we are writing for our system
we know what it is we want to do machine
translation we know exactly what we want
to do and it's very clear but sometimes
it's actually not clear what we should
be optimizing right like your Facebook
or say wants to make money like should
they optimize for clicks is that an
ethical like rewards function to put in
and what could be some of the effects of
optimizing for clicks let's say that I
have a reinforcement learning algorithm
I'm making yourself let's say I have a
reinforcement learning algorithm that
wants to optimize for clicks and after
and I have my own Facebook account and
it's optimizing clicks from dorsa right
so so this reinforcement learning
algorithm what it can do is it can learn
that well maybe if I show outrageous
articles to the Ursa norsu is more
likely to click on these outrageous
articles and then I'm gonna get more
rewards because I'm optimizing for a
quick so that's all good right that's
expected but another thing that the
reinforcement learning algorithm by
itself can figure out is that if I shall
outrageous articles to dorsa diversa is
going to become more and more outrageous
and then I'm gonna get more quicks
because then I'm gonna show more
articles and it'll be great and that's
kind of amazing because these systems
are not interacting in a closed-loop
world like during our
thing with other systems like humans who
are also changing or also adapting and
and the system through this our
algorithm by itself could figure out how
to change me to like more outrageous
things and then we would end up in a
situation where we are right now with
very bipolar views right because because
you're optimizing for cliques so so it's
quite interesting to think about what
are the objects is we should be
optimizing and what world are we dealing
with you're not always like in a pac-man
world where we can control everything
right like usually these systems are
running in a real society where there
are people being affected by them and
their responses are going to change and
there is the changes in their responses
is going to affect things even more so
so it's interesting to think about these
feedback loops and speaking of humans I
think another thing and not another
question that comes up usually when it
comes to robotics orange comes today is
well what is it that humans want like in
general even even in the case of
robotics is a big problem I have a robot
arm and I want my robot arm to pick up
pick up this object that's all I want
right this is the thing that me as a
human wants right I want the robot up to
pick up and the robot arm to pick up
this mobile phone so back in the day
this was called good engineering right
good engineering was good engineers
would write down the correct reward
function and the correct objective and
the robot arm would go and pick up the
object and everything would be great the
problem is that doesn't always work
right it's really hard to write the
correct reward function and get the
robot do that and because of that people
these days are more interested in trying
to do things around imitation learning
or things around preference based
learning where you just try to learn
from how humans do it like how a human
would do this as opposed to like just a
human sitting down and saying well this
is the object if I want you to become
pickup the robot arm because because the
robot might end up doing very weird
things like an example of that that
commonly comes up is this vacuum cleaner
example let's say let's say you have a
vacuum cleaner you have a robot vacuum
cleaner that wants to clean your house
and your objective for the vacuum
cleaner is to suck up dirt that that's
all it needs to do okay so you write
your objective everything is great and
one way that the vacuum cleaner could
suck up to it is it could just go to a
place suck up dirt put it out suck up
dirt put it out so
put it out and just keep doing that
right obviously you didn't want your
vacuum you do we don't want that vacuum
cleaner because you didn't want your
vacuum cleaner to do that or that wasn't
the thing you were thinking but the
objective of go suck up dirt could end
up in that behavior another behavior it
could end up with as you could have your
vacuum cleaner and your vacuum cleaner
by itself could just break its own like
sensors so now it doesn't sense dirt now
you're good because there are no dirts
around us because you can't see them I'm
gonna close my eyes so I can't see the
dirt so I'm not gonna suck up anything
so so all of these are things around
reward hacking like if you if you just
write the reward function that you think
the robot should optimize it's not
necessarily going to work and thinking
about what are some good objectives that
you should optimize is actually a really
difficult problem and this is something
that I'm very interested in in my group
we focus on that a lot actually another
work that has recently came out on this
is this work by this this new book by
Stuart Russell on human compatible and
and basically what Stuart is kind of
arguing is is the fact that there's a
mismatch between what humans actually
want what is the reward function that's
in their head and then what is it that
that the AI system or the robot thinks
the human wants and then those two are
not always the same thing and that could
cause a lot of issues around it so
interesting we'll take a look all right
what else can go wrong so
generating fake content that was the
thing that came out a couple years back
so so you could create like videos that
just or images that look exactly like
like Obama in this case and and you can
just put fake content on that and and
that that again raises an ethical
question right just because you can
build it should you build it or not like
we can build that right like we have the
we have the system to create a fake
content it sounds fine but but should we
do it just because we can do it
another place that this question comes
up and and I do encourage you guys in
general to think about that in your
future like when you can build something
but but you do build it and and yeah
another place this comes up is in
autonomous weapons systems so having
like thinking about military and then
thinking about having autonomous weapons
right like we would have we could but
you can have autonomous weapons these
days we can have systems that
automatically detect an enemy and and
automatically just stupid like just do
the job right yeah you do the task so um
should we do it should we have
autonomous weapon systems or does there
need to be a person in the loop and if
so so it was just like thinking about it
like let's say that yeah we do not we
never want to have autonomous weapon
systems and we always want to have a
person in the loop
well why like look what is it about the
person that we want to be in the loop
like that kind of tells us that there is
something about the person maybe it's
empathy maybe this something about what
what people know or what people have
that that the autonomous system doesn't
have yet and just like understanding
that I think by itself is a very
interesting problem and there's a whole
debate around this like of autonomous
servant systems should we have them if
we don't have them what if other
countries have them like how do we go
about it
should you put a moratorium on it and
lots of debates around these types of
systems so so in general I do encourage
you to think about some of these ethical
aspects of building AI systems all right
next stop fairness so so far this is a
big problem I think a lot of you know
this already right so so we might have a
classifier that purr like on your
majority of data set perfectly separates
your majority of data set such as the
the picture on the left and then you
might have some data points from
minority group and the classifier just
does exactly the opposite thing for the
minority group so so if you if you put
all these data together then you're
probably going to get data a classifier
that looks like the first one and it's
just not gonna work on the minority data
set and and that is kind of that's a big
problem especially like when it comes to
applications like let's say health care
like you might have different
populations and a drug might just act
very differently on different
populations and the question is how
should we address these fairness
questions and one way to go about it is
to think about our errors so so you
might have two classifiers and both of
them might give you five person error
but one of them could give you five
percent random error and
could give you 5% systematic error and
and I think it's pretty important to
think about if you're getting systemic
error random error and what type of
error on what population are you getting
and and that could address some of these
questions around fairness there's a lot
of work actually around fairness these
days there's a there's a conference
around it around furnace accountability
and transparency this is work by more
its heart so if you're interested in
these take a look at some of the some of
the work from where it's another example
of fairness I think we did talk about
this and the overview lecture is around
this criminal risk assessment so it's a
North Point is a company that put out
the system called comm-pass and what
comm-pass does is is it predicts if a
criminal is going to reoffended not the
risk of a criminal reoffending or not
and it's going to give the score of 1
through 10 so that's what the system
does and and they put out the system
this system was actually being used and
what happened was probably which is a
non-profit came out and did a study and
ProPublica showed that given that an
individual did not reoffending americans
were twice likely to be wrongly
classified 5 or above okay so that just
seemed not fair so so republic up with
us puts out this article being like whoa
the system is not fair why are we using
this like it doesn't satisfy this
fairness criteria and then Northpoint
actually did further studies north when
did further studies and they showed that
well they said well now our system is
fair because we're looking at this
definition of fairness our definition of
fairness is that given a risk score of
seven sixty percent of whites reoffended
and sixty percent of blacks reoffended
so we want to make sure that we get the
same percentage to be fair and that's
our furnace furnace property we do
satisfy that and this kind of this these
two furnace definitions
kind of made a group of researchers from
actually Stanford Cornell a bunch of
different places to start thinking about
definitions of fairness and what they've
actually shown is that these two
definitions of fairness they are not
going to be satisfied at the same time
they're always going to go against each
other we can't have both of them at the
same time so so then if that is the case
then what is the right definition of
fairness that we should use right
and have both of those at the same time
then then how do we make sure that we
can use these or should we ever use
these systems again
so um lots of interesting questions
about formalizing furnace or moraine
gold here in the cs department works a
lot around the ideas of fairness from
the algorithmic side of things so if
you're interested in that you can take
homers classes learn learn about that
and I'm kind of going back to this idea
of our algorithms neutral like when you
talk to people who haven't taken
necessarily algorithm classes or AI
classes do you usually think well yeah
all right algorithms gotta be neutral
like they're doing math they gotta be
neutral but as we've seen already
they're not really neutral because by
design you really want our algorithms to
pick up patterns that's what they're
good at they're good at picking up
patterns and and biases and all sorts of
weird things that we see in our data
they're just in our data their patterns
in our data and these algorithms just
will pick them up and even reinforce
them at times and that's why we see bias
in our algorithms and all these issues
around fairness and security and all
these other things in our data and an
another problem that comes up is this
feedback loop that I was talking about
earlier right so so if algorithms are
picking up patterns well they're putting
out in those patterns if they have
biases they're putting out those biases
in a world where there are humans and
those humans are observing those biases
and can get even more biased and give
more biased data and and this could be
like this negative feedback loop that
could go forever so again we got to be
really careful about what we were
putting at and and what it is like how
it is affecting the bigger society next
stop is privacy I guess I have like a
couple of more things around these and
after that I'll wrap up another another
thing another issue in general is
privacy right so if you're using a lot
of data and and in a lot of our
algorithms and and in general some of
them could be could be sensitive data
and we don't want to we don't want to
actually reveal that sensitive data so
so big to address that one way to
address that is instead of putting out
the actual data putting out the right
statistics that gives us the right
information so for example you might
want to compute the average statistics
and like if you're asking if someone
cancer or not instead of getting the
yes/no answer you could just you might
just need the average statistics and
that would just be enough for you so in
general when you're collecting data you
should shoot you could randomize your
data or you could change your data so
you can get the average statistics as
one way of protecting privacy another
way of protecting privacy is in general
randomize responses so so you might have
a question of like do you have a sibling
so that is a question you can ask a user
and the user might not want to reveal
exactly if they have a sibling or not so
so one way of responding that is the
user could flip two coins and then if
both of them can come heads then they
can say answer yes no randomly otherwise
they can answer yes no truthfully so so
based on the answer that you get from a
particular user you wouldn't be able to
tell if that particular user is going to
have it has a sibling or not but you
could actually compute the true
probability of that because now you have
observed this probability 3/4 of the
time there by true probabilities are
telling you the truth 1/4 of the time
they're telling you randomly so so then
you have this observed probability and
then from that you can recover the true
probability and that is probably enough
for like the type of data that you need
to deal with so so randomized responses
in general could be one way of going
about some of these privacy issues
another issue that comes up is causality
so this is a little bit and in the
variable based models right so so you
might want to look at the effects of
something let's say you want to look at
the effects of a treatment on survival
and this is your data so you have 4
untreated patients 80% of them survived
and 4 treated patients 30% survived this
is your data so the question is does
treatment help or not
how many of you think treatment helps
so so the answer is actually who knows
because well if you think about it
they're sick people are probably more
likely to take treatment right like if
sick people are more likely to undergo
treatment then then you can't really
like Texas theta like as it at its face
and say well treatment helped or didn't
help because your your data actually
there's this extra causality that you
didn't really consider the fact that
well those people who took trip and they
were sick so you have to actually
consider that how the sickness is going
to affect and the the rate of survival
or not and finally the last I think this
was the last thing I wanted to briefly
talk about is is this idea of
interpretability versus accuracy right
so you've seen kind of just rise of
neural networks and a lot of
applications and most of them are not
safety-critical applications we haven't
really seen like things like neural
networks and safety-critical
applications I guess you've seen it in
cars so we have started saying in
autonomous cars but let's say airplanes
or or like other types of safety
critical systems healthcare systems and
and one question that always comes up is
should we use these systems in safety
critical settings because as we were
using them you're going to lose
interpretability so so there's this work
by Michael Cooke in their first group
where they were basically looking at air
traffic control and and and they're
looking at the system that runs on
aircraft and then previously it was
basically a bunch of rules that the
system it needed to follow but it was
interpretable like like they could
actually interpret it and understand
what it does and then the system's the
aircraft systems would use that but
michael has been working with this new
system called a Cass
and a Cass Xu where they are basically
trying to replace that with just let's
say upon VP a partially observable
Markov decision process that that does
the same job but it is not necessarily
this it doesn't have necessarily the
same level interpretability but it's
pretty accurate you can prove that it's
even accurate it's not even a neural
network right it is a thing that you can
actually like enumerate and and the
question is what are we going to put in
on our safety critical systems if you
lose transparency if you lose
interpretability are we still willing to
put these systems that we think there
are statistically more accurate and in
general how can we increase interpret
ability and transparency of some of
these systems that we are building
because that is useful and we can really
think about these systems so sorryi is
important I think I think I've convinced
you guys that AI is important and then
all these different governments also
think that AI is important in 2016 the
White House put out an article about
some of the directions that we should
invest money in and a lot of them were
just around the eye so making long-term
investments in AI research thinking
about human eye collaboration thinking
about ethical and legal and societal
implications of AI safety and security
of AI systems so all of these things
that we have been discussing so far are
really challenging problems and then
everyone's excited about them and
everyone wants to put in putting a lot
of energy and time and money in it and
and in this document
well the sacraments that big data
analytics have the potential to eclipse
long-standing civil rights protections
in how personal information is used in
all sorts of applications like housing
credit employment and so on and
Americans relationships with data should
expand not diminish their opportunities
and some of the things that we have
discussed so far
right like biases fairness safety all of
these issues are not necessarily
satisfying this last sentence right like
if you're building these these systems
we should actually be really careful
about some of these implications and and
as I was saying earlier like around this
there's a new conference there's this
fact ml conference around fairness
accountability and transparency and kind
of the guidelines of this new community
that that's being built around AI is
that we got to think about the fact that
there's always a human that's behind
these algorithms so there's always a
human ultimately responsible behind what
is going to happen and then we can't
just say well the algorithm did it like
in general like that's just like the
wrong way of going this because there's
a human designer one of you guys one of
us right that's going to write these
algorithms and and I do really want you
guys to think about some of these
principles as you go further in your in
your career and you think about building
this sort of AI are
and just to end on a more positive note
there's an enormous potential for
actually positive impact for AI systems
and then please just use it responsibly
that I want to thank you guys for this
exciting quarter and please fill out the
surveys on axis thanks
[Applause]